[Music]
meet Mel B's golden buzzer Amanda Mina
the 15 year old singer who wowed the
America's Got Talent judge with her
Aretha Franklin cover
[Music]
he's going straight to the live shows
walking back to that moment what was
going through your mind when mal reached
over and hit that golden buzzer I really
couldn't believe it like I I kind of
blacked out for a second I was like what
is happening is this real life that was
just incredible
what do you think it is about you that
she connected to the most I think we
both believe in the same similar thing
like empowerment for young women amanda
says she was bullied when she was
younger and hopes for music inspires
kids just like her I got made fun of a
lot that really hurt
if you could say anything to your
bullies now what would you say I don't
wanna say thank you cuz they taught me a
lot and the experiences that I had
before right now I can deal with it
better there's a lot of girls that don't
feel good about themselves and don't
feel beautiful and so I want to put in
my music things that inspire them to
believe that they are amazing
[Music]
natural woman
[Music]
she's my golden buzzer she's gonna win
the whole thing
[Music]